if anyone doubts the sheer might of the
security services in Venezuela take a
look at this and one of the main
highways in Caracas a road block is
supported by water Canon wagons behind
that armored cars wood mounted tear gas
tubes then the National Guard in riot
gear on trucks and finally the
much-feared military intelligence
remember this is just one shot of one
unit who many more across the city there
were rallies for both when we do' and
nicolas maduro the street is packed with
opposition supporters trying to get from
the east of caracas an opposition
stronghold to the west which largely
supports Maduro they've come out in
their thousands but it was clear that
for the first time in weeks the
government had decided to disrupt the
opposition rally National Guard blocked
all the main routes across town trucks
known as vampires extend sideways across
the road they're supported by National
Guard this way is closed
despite this the opposition supporters
say they remain as determined as ever
but nothing much is changing it will
change but it's gonna be I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be the whole worries looking
out
the all warrants waiting for Venezuela
recover the freedom and this why we need
freedom on motorbikes we tried to make
better headway time and again the way
was blocked there's a big operation here
to stop or at least try to suppress this
demonstration this police absolutely
everywhere National Guard as well
most of the routes are blocked heavily
armed riot police we're trying to find
our way through but it's quite clear
that this is a concerted effort to
suppress the rallies that have been
absolutely huge for weeks finally in the
west of the city
we found the rally and when glider on
the roof of a car there were thousands
upon thousands here nobody could really
hear him and nobody really cared his
actions said it all and they loved
failed to do that they've definitely
stopped people from the eastern
from the Westside
we lost again no stage the people who
are setting up her arrested
significant turnout I think it also
indicates fit
security forces here
so far today they failed supporters of
nicolas maduro also took to the streets
in caracas whatever the opposition does
here he remains in absolute control but
the country has been hit with days of
blackouts virtually nothing is working
it's brought absolute chaos this is a
fuel queue in an oil-rich country
ironically it may not be a political
power struggle that damages Maduro but a
much more mundane and perhaps more
dangerous power cut steel Ramsey Sky
News Caracas